republics were edited surrogates against
American and allies interests and they
should be understood in the context of
40 years of unprovoked aggression
against freedom-loving nations on April
22nd Iran promised the world would
interrupt the flow of oil to the Strait
of Hormuz it is now working to execute
on that promise in early May the
Revolutionary Guard Corps attempted the
covert deployment of modified douse
capable of launching of missiles on May
12 we're an attack for commercial ships
illustrative for moose I've made 14
transact surrogates attacked by armed
drones struck 232 important oil
pipelines in the Saudi Arabia on May
19th a rocket landed near the US Embassy
in Baghdad on May 31st a car bomb in
Afghanistan will be for us service
members killed for Afghan civilians and
wounded bystanders yesterday Iranian
surrogates partner missile decided
rather striking the arrival of terminal
by the International Airport injuring 26
piece taken as a whole these unprovoked
attacks presented clear threat to
international peace and security a
blatant assault on the freedom of
navigation and an unacceptable campaign
Abascal any attention by Ron Prime
Minister Amin Amin a trip historic trip
to write to ask the regime to deescalate
and enter into talks
Iran's supreme leader rejected prime
minister obvious diplomacy today by
saying he has no response to President
Trump and will not answer the Supreme
Leader's government that insulted Japan
by attacking a Japanese are on the oil
tanker just outside of Iranian waters
threatening the lives of the entire crew
creating a maritime emergency rats
Foreign Minister today responded to
these attacks
he said sardonically well suspicious
doesn't begin to describe what likely
transpired this morning end of quote
foreign minister zarif may think this is
funny but no one else in the world does
Iran is lashing out because the regime
wants our successful maximum pressure
campaign lifted no economic sanctions a
ton of Islamic Republic to attack
innocent civilians disrupt global oil
markets and engage in nuclear blackmail
the international community condemns
Iran an assault on the freedom of
navigation and the targeting of innocent
civilians today I've instructed our UN
Ambassador Jonathan Cohen to raise
Iran's attacks in the UN Security
Council meeting later this afternoon our
policy remains an economic and
diplomatic efforts to bring the run back
to the negotiating table at the right
time to encourage a comprehensive deal
that addresses the broad range of
threats threats today apparent from all
of the world to see to peace
LaRon should meet diplomacy with
disfluency now with terror bloodshed and
extortion the United States will defend
its forces pictures instead with our
partners and allies to safeguard global
commerce and regional stability we call
upon all nations threatened by Rask
evocative acts to join us in that
endeavor